how are you button fans trendy with the
reunion yeah what everybody think it's
real yeah Matt no we just we were there
for JC's birthday that's what it was for
and we drank a lot triangle I did how
was the night was fun it was a blast
acts she was uh a bunch of his close
friends shut down the place nice guy and
just hung out had a great time just
really just had dinner and just had a
cake and just kind of reminisce and hung
out really what happened I love that you
guys are still so close that's why
you're better than one direction exactly
yeah I mean we we actually do
legitimately like each other we whenever
we would never really look together per
se we everybody knew somebody in the
group one way shape or form so it's
never like oh you're gonna [ __ ] and you
look like a good-looking guy and that's
the young one and that's the dumb one so
let's put you guys together but now we
all kind of knew each other so we still
remain friends multi-talented
multifaceted right yes I try and they
all try what you guys do a reunion
though without ever I mean I you know
you spark to no yags up work you know
you know for me I always say anytime in
the rabbit Never Say Never but I mean
for us it's like everybody's doing kind
of like their own thing really and it's
it's been great though it's nice to be
able to kind of we didn't leave on a bad
note with no Limone
you know nothing was wrong you know I'm
just saying everybody kind of did their
own thing and obviously as you get older
you want to experience and do other
things I mean that's why everybody
mentioned off into other things so just
instilled you know stinging and being a
dad Chris actually is moving out - is
that Nashville right now JC's been
riding lands have been doing radio stuff
I'm gonna be selling off dog sir I don't
we didn't appreciate you enough because
I'm sorry they believed in us we never
deserved Joey Fatone that's awesome